je suis désolé de te dire ça c'est la
même manière contre l'énergie non mais
il n'y a pas de souci tu peux même me
confesser mais le truc c'est quoi c'est
que lorsque denis était la thur mettait
même en doute et si c'était pas cyril
qui te dit calme toi t'aurais continue
et sert quand on te dit que posent les
questions il annonce n'était pas des
questions parce que le fait de dire
signé attendent maria tendre à petit
l'orbité un peu son style ouais mais
fait son style et le monde dit moi je
suis pas chroniqueur j'ai pas le cerveau
pour avancer être chroniqueur mais non
savoir pas six mois
[Musique]
c'est manière dégueulasse pourriez pas
fondées mais tu m'appelles mon chat je
vais t'appeler ma petite fille tiers
attention on dira le 2e jean michel
maire mais là s'arrête à bras de fer
autrement dit autrement mais vas-y bras
de fer le moteur
bah oui et le père dont je vais la
donner déjà vous dire je vous avais tu
as plus beau fort heureusement oui allez
on y va y aller former deux peuples nous
allons prendre plein la gueule
les jets ont été redessinés aucune
chance plus qu'autre chose mais
attention car je vais pas perdre à
partir et je peux pas te pète un câble
[Applaudissements]
bravo vous avez voulu la paix vous savez
ce qu'on va faire on va passer tout de
suite à la finale entre moi et moody's
allaient me l'a bien content ça pour la
finale ça va être ça va être une moc a
appelé à mener la bataille là c'est
foutu
alors attention vous dire je le dis au
bal vert ou chifoumi en 2.4 sushis et
fumeurs de coire et pierre feuille
ciseaux bien fait sinon attention c'est
pas c'est la mode start c'est lui qui
l'a fait attention pierre pierre feuille
ciseaux à 9,6 au couple à feuilles
pierre feuille ciseaux le ciseau coupe
encore lafarge gagné 2 0 merci monsieur
les
merci monsieur veut dire que j'adore et
je dis merci la rochelle
[Musique]